there's no way that he can win no no
anyway what'd you think of the season
for now they Game of Thrones I'm reading
the books first book any read slow hey
has anybody seen that new Russell Crowe
thriller because let me sorry it's just
we're going tomorrow and I don't want to
know a thing about it doesn't want to
know a thing okay
I'm gonna watch it later
oh you oh you guys I gotta start okay
yeah so yeah what's the weather gonna be
like this sorry it sounds we're having a
barbecue this weekend and I don't want
to stress about the weather no of course
you don't we just yeah yeah
mr. bean casserole is gone I'm so sorry
babe I just I hadn't tasted him yet
tonight
I'm sorry looking forward to don't talk
about the ingredients I know
yeah after this surprise for your mouth
oh if you got you know that commercial
with it's probably best yeah
cheesecake got cheesecake I mean oh yeah
know what yeah I'm not a cheese cake
let's do that yeah I mean I've been
watching my cholesterol intake but what
the hell right I'm gonna die someday
anyway right what honey
Wow are you just ruin it everyone I'll
see you at home
dude that's how would you not know that
that was taking place
you